Coca-Cola was going to cure morphine
addiction bubble wrap was supposed to be
a trendy new textured wallpaper and
YouTube was going to be the premier
video dating app more often failed
products don't lead to Accidental
successes but they're nevertheless an
essential feature of capitalism it was
Carl Marx who set out to bring
production under conscious control
correcting for the anarchic forces of
the free market but it turned out that
anarchy risk-taking and the freedom to
try out wild ideas is the only process
that leads to successful Innovation
because nobody can predict consumer
tastes a doll that grows breasts a hoola
chair for office workers a virtual
reality glove that hit the market in
1989 these and other commercial flops
are on display at the Museum of failure
in Washington
DC we are very much trying kind of have
fun with this exhibit so people like to
make fun of the fact that we are on the
site of a failed gym Yana Gutman is one
of the organizers of the exhibit it's
the brainchild of Dr Samuel West he is
the curator of the show and he realized
that the most successful companies were
those that had a high failure rate so he
started to explore this concept of
failure because everyone loves to talk
about success no one likes to talk about
failure when in fact failure is a much
better teacher than success is the
Segway is actually a perfect example
because some people will say well why
would you call the segue a failure the
expectation with the Segway was that
entire city infrastructures would be
built around Segways and people would
use it as a mode of transportation but
today we really use Segways I mean we
all think of that movie mov right and
those tourist tours that's essentially
where they've been relegated
to meet new Growing Up Skipper she's two
dolls in one cuz when you turn her arm
you can make her change instantly from a
little girl to a tall slender teenage
doll which is something you can't do
it's such a like creepy thing that she
like develops breasts you get two dolls
in one there could not have been any
women at that table right I think that
and the pregnant Barbie came out around
the same time so it was like who was
thinking about this right I know it's
bizarre it's bizarre so there definitely
is a tone deafness sometimes in in uh
marketing there are like quite a few
products in here that are like quote
unquote before their time you have
something very similar that it looks
like V goggles but it's obviously
obviously not virtual reality or AI
right yeah sometimes there are marketing
reasons why something is marketed poorly
and that that leads to the product's
failure CL the discreet sanitary
solution for your urgent relief guys how
many times has this happened to you come
on you know you can't hold it in that
long don't worry I've got the perfect
gift for you
sometimes it's just a timing issue but
those things kind of pave the way for
how we see our products exactly so we
actually have Google Glass which is
great because nobody would consider
Google a failure as a company even
though not every product sort of hit the
mark but people are now saying number
one a new Google Glass is coming out we
actually had a posted at at the New York
show where somebody said stay tuned they
work at Google and a new one is coming
out and it was Anonymous so
we have so many big issues to deal with
if we're only going to go with safe
choices or things that we know that
absolutely will work we probably are
going to end up with nothing so we want
to solve big problems we're going to
have to try and sometimes the technology
like with the Nintendo glove which was
very people were super excited about it
when it came out but it had all these
buttons that really didn't do anything
but the same technology was used for the
Wii which was a very big Commercial
Success so sometimes the same technology
is used used also uh for a following
product but tech companies in general
are really good at sort of learning from
their mistakes and I don't want to
really even call it mistakes but
learning from through trial and error
and taking in that
feedback we are trying to provoke a
conversation about failure about success
about Innovation the museum also has a
section devoted to Elon Musk who love
him or hate him from PayPal to SpaceX
from Tesla to starlink is one of the
most successful entrepreneurs of our
time but that has a lot to do with his
willingness to take wild risks failure
must be an option if failure is not an
option it's going to result in extremely
conservative choices
and you may not may have get something
even worse than lack of innovation
things may go backwards he's just really
pushing that envelope all the time and
he makes us think he's provocative which
we are trying to
be and we definitely want to encourage
people to take meaningful risks I also
think that we live in a time where
social media amplifies everything and I
think young people have this real fear
of failing because it's going to follow
me forever or it's going to seem maybe
bigger than it is because it is on
social media so we're trying to really
sort of make people more comfortable
with this idea that not everything is
going to work out the way we planned or
the way we had want it if we're always
going to be safe and take the safe route
so that we almost can guarantee success
then we're not going to solve big
problems and and and address situations
because we're not taking any risks and
then we don't innovate and we don't
progress there are catastrophic failures
happening all around us and we're so
much richer because of
it